you know out of all the apple cider
vinegar videos on youtube
i have video that has the most views 14
million views and this morning i tried
to find it i couldn't even find it it's
out there but apparently it's just not
listed so if you're trying to find some
interesting information about apple
cider vinegar
you may not find my videos so this is
why i decided to do another video just
to kind of give you a
summary of what was in that last video
and also some new information because
this video the one that got 14 million
views six years ago was done before
there was some really interesting
research done in apple cider vinegar in
relationship to helping someone lose
their belly fat so i'm going to share
that new data today as well but there's
a lot of benefits to consuming apple
cider vinegar and i'm going to recommend
the amounts that you need per day so let
me just first dive into a study that
wasn't around six years ago but this
study was done on 175 japanese
participants and they were done on obese
people and this study was double-blinded
and this is what they found over 12
weeks they found significant benefits in
reducing visceral fat that's the fat
around the gut in reducing subcutaneous
fat that's the fat just beneath the skin
in reducing triglycerides cholesterol
increasing the bmi
and also decreasing
body fat as well as decreasing the waist
to hip ratio i mean this is pretty
amazing because back six years ago um
the only studies that i could find were
on mice and there is some interesting
information on mice if you have an obese
pet mouse you definitely need to start
giving an apple cider vinegar because it
can inhibit the expression of lipogenic
genes
those genes are genes that increase fat
production so apple cider vinegar can
inhibit the expression of those genes
which is pretty cool i mean who wants a
bunch of fat mice running around your
house so the acid in
apple cider vinegar is called acetic
acid and so it has been known to
suppress body fat now that's probably
because of what it does to insulin
because it really helps you regulate
your blood sugars and that's primarily
what i talked about
six years ago now you would think that
consuming something acid would make the
body more acid and because
acid is an unhealthy state
then you shouldn't be consuming apple
cider vinegar that's completely false
information our bodies should not be one
ph every different part of your body has
a different ph your stomach is extremely
acid your gallbladder material is
slightly alkaline your small intestine
is slightly alkaline your urine should
be slightly acid your large intestine
should be acid but not extremely acid
like the stomach and so we need these
different phs to activate different
enzymes for a lot of different purposes
so apple cider vinegar would support the
stomach acids okay so it'll help you
digest better in the stomach level is
exactly where the start of digestion
occurs right i mean it does start in the
mouth with chewing but the stomach is
like the incinerator that's where you
have these really strong acids like a ph
of one to three i mean that's like like
battery acid and that hydrochloric acid
is gonna release enzymes to start
breaking down protein and really do a
number on your food and so
you wouldn't want to alkalize the
stomach okay and this is why apple cider
vinegar is used in a lot of digestive
problems so you definitely want to use
apple cider vinegar
for helping you lose more weight and
roughly within 12 weeks you could
potentially lose an extra two to four
pounds might not sound like a lot but if
you look at how much two to four pounds
of actual fat is
that's significant and especially if
it's targeting the midsection and the
subcutaneous fat just beneath the skin
as well as supporting your blood sugars
and helping you with insulin resistance
which is at the core of a slow
metabolism so
very simply this is what i recommend you
do
you basically take one ounce of apple
cider vinegar that's two tablespoons or
30 milliliters of apple cider vinegar
okay and you're going to pour that in
about an 8 ounce glass of water and you
also might want to add in there some
lemon juice okay
what i do is i take a whole lemon i
blend it in the water i put my apple
cider vinegar in there with it and then
i put a scoop of my electrolyte powder
which has all the electrolytes the trace
minerals and it's sweetened with stevia
and it's flavored so it tastes really
good because sometimes the apple cider
vinegar can be a little bit on the
bitter side and if you don't want to use
electrolytes you can just put some
stevia in there maybe 10 drops so it'll
be sweet and if you have lemon in there
it'll taste like lemonade and just
realize if you're going to use lemon
juice out of a bottle there's not going
to be a lot of vitamin c in there but if
you use a whole lemon you're going to
have a lot of vitamin c and i do
recommend the whole lemon so you put in
the blender blend it up and then slug it
down twice a day once in the morning and
once
in the evening so basically you're doing
a total of four tablespoons of apple
cider vinegar every single day
split up and i would recommend doing
this on a regular basis if you're
concerned about your teeth because of
this acid just use a straw now the only
time i don't recommend consuming apple
cider vinegar is
during a prolonged fast
because you're going to be in some major
ketosis and you're going to be pretty
acid so we wouldn't want to necessarily
put more acid and what i mean by a
prolonged fast is anything longer than
like a 48 hour fast i'm not talking
about regular intermittent fasting every
day okay and then there's another
situation that i wouldn't recommend it
is if you had an ulcer in your stomach
okay but you'll know that really quick
because when you drink it you'll have
more pain in your stomach but other than
that if you wanted something a little
extra to help you lose a little more
weight
you might want to try that and because
it's difficult to find that outside of
vinegar video that hit 14 million views
i put it up right here
check it out
you